schauen wir auf den bundeskanzler von
österreich sebastian kurz der hat sich
gerade eben vor der presse geäußert
ja wir erleben gerade alle gemeinsam
eine herausfordernde zeit für unser land
für die europäische union und für weite
teile der welt darüber hinaus ich bin
mir vollkommen bewusst dass es eine
extreme anstrengung für viele von ihnen
ist das soziale leben auf ein minimum zu
reduzieren das bedeutet verzicht es
bedeutet teilweise auch einsamkeit und
das bedeutet eine komplette umstellung
für uns alle in österreich
ich bin mir vollkommen bewusst dass das
nicht einfach ist und daher möchte ich
gleich zu beginn alle österreicherinnen
und österreichern ihnen allen ein großes
danke sagen für ihren verzicht für ihre
entschleunigung für ihre anstrengungen
in diesen tagen denn das ist ein ganz
wesentlicher beitrag den jeder im moment
leisten kann
ich möchte darüber hinaus all jenen
danken die in diesen tagen über sich
hinaus wachsen weil sie an ihrem
arbeitsplatz oder auch in der
freiwilligentätigkeit ganz
beeindruckendes für andere menschen
leisten und ich möchte auch den
mitgliedern der bundesregierung aber
auch den landeshauptleuten und natürlich
den parteichefs aller im parlament
vertretenen parteien danke sagen für die
gute kooperation und für den stetigen
austausch den wir fast täglich auch
pflegen viele menschen rufen mich an
oder kontaktieren mich im moment und
sagen sie wollen wissen wie das alles
weitergeht
sie wollen endlich wissen ob die
maßnahmen greifen
und wie lange wir das alles ertragen
müssen
und sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
bemühe mich diese frage möglichst
ehrlich zu beantworten und die ehrliche
antwort darauf ist wir haben noch kein
valides zahlenmaterial
ich bitte sie um geduld bis freitag wir
sind vollkommen überzeugt davon dass wir
das richtige tun aber wie anfangs schon
gesagt brauchen die maßnahmen eine zeit
lang bis sie greifen
wir werden daher am freitag ein valides
zahlenmaterial haben und sie sehr
geehrte österreicherinnen und
österreicher darüber informieren wie
stark die maßnahmen greifen und mit
welchem szenario wird zu rechnen haben
bis dahin gibt es aber genug zu tun und
auch genug wo jeder einzelne einen
beitrag leisten kann ich möchte ganz
bewusst hier nicht alle maßnahmen
ansprechen aber doch auf drei
prioritäten an denen wir derzeit
arbeiten fokussieren zum ersten regeln
einhalten
ich hab's eingangs schon gesagt das
verhalten dass wir alle an den tag legen
das hat direkte auswirkungen auf die
frage wie es uns in ein paar wochen in
österreich gehen wird wir alle haben es
in der hand alles zu tun dass es in
österreich keine zustände wie in italien
oder spanien gibt und ich möchte daher
ein großes danke allen österreicherinnen
und österreicher sagen dass sich
diszipliniert an die vorgegebenen
maßnahmen halten
ich habe aber auch den innenminister
ersucht die wenigen zu strafen die sich
nicht daran halten und somit den erfolg
aller gefährden wir können nicht
zulassen dass einzelne nicht nur sich
selbst sondern vor allem andere menschen
in gefahr bringen
und der innenminister hat daher auch
angeordnet dass die polizei hier
restriktiv diejenigen strafen wird die
sich nicht
an die maßnahmen halten und somit die
gesundheit der österreicherinnen und
österreicher in summe gefährden
zweitens kapazitäten schaffen
neben guten medizinischen personal und
ausreichend betten für den ernstfall
braucht es natürlich auch
schutzausrüstung und den ausbau der test
kapazitäten
ich möchte mich hier beim
gesundheitsminister der
wirtschaftsministerin der
verteidigungsministerin und auch dem
roten kreuz dafür bedanken dass intensiv
an beschaffung produktion und logistik
in diesem bereich gearbeitet wird es
treffen stetig lieferungen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen bei uns ein
aus deutschland aus malaysien und ganz
besonders auch aus der volksrepublik
china
hier unser ausdrücklicher dank für 20
millionen schutzmasken die wir von der
volksrepublik china erhalten werden die
ersten fünf millionen werden schon diese
woche eintreffen
zu den tests neben der reduktion des
sozialen lebens neben der notwendigkeit
den betrieb in österreich auf notbetrieb
herunterzufahren ist das wichtigste ziel
testen testen testen je mehr wir testen
desto besser
und daher habe ich die bundesländer aber
auch den gesundheitsminister sucht alles
zu tun um die test kapazitäten zu
steigern
es wird gelingen die kapazitäten auf
rund 15.000 pro tag auszubauen und diese
auch durchzuführen sofern wir auch die
notwendigen ressourcen dafür vom
weltmarkt erhalten
darüber hinaus werden wir auf
schnelltests setzen wir sind hier gerade
in der endabstimmung um möglichst
schnell
auch die kapazitäten zu haben dann
hunderttausende menschen breitenwirksam
zu testen diese schnelltests haben nicht
dieselbe qualität wie die tests mit
denen wir derzeit arbeiten das ist
richtig dieser einwand aber es ist die
einzige möglichkeit um auch wirklich
hunderttausende menschen und nicht nur
wenige zu testen
darüber hinaus besteht eine besondere
herausforderung im bereich der pflege
wir rechnen mit dem ausfall vieler
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
diesem bereich der pflege unter 24
stunden betreuung